néanmoins il ya des valeurs communes que
défendent en tout cas tout c'est parti
patriote
quelles sont-elles jean philippe tanguy
et autour de quel projet justement c'est
droite pourraient s'unir selon selon le
président de debout la france
c'est une idée très simple qui peuvent
peut être vous paraître naïve mais qui
face à emmanuel macron n'est pas si naïf
c'est déjà l'amour de la france l'amour
de la france de sa culture la défense de
ses intérêts par exemple ne pas
dilapider les entreprises nationales
alstom technip au vent c'est défendre
une diplomatie française on voit avec
l'iran que monsieur macron s'est
précipité pour défendre les états unis
qui venait d'assassiner général iranien
sans même avoir le début de la fin d'une
enquête pour avant se prononcer quand
même ce sont des choses graves
les exemples sont très nombreux donc
l'amour de la france est très important
le respect des français le respect de la
démocratie
aussi sans doute une nouvelle forme de
démocratie plus directe et c'est enfin
le plus important le respect du travail
c'est quand même la valeur fondamentale
des partis de droite en général mais
aussi des partis populaires qu'on ne
puisse plus vivre de son travail en
france est un scandale
le fondamental et je pense que tous nos
parties pourraient se mettre d'accord
sur un vrai une vraie façon de mieux
rémunérer le travail des nouvelles
formes la participation dans les
entreprises
le capitalisme populaire est en fait la
primaire pourquoi est ce qu'on veut une
première aussi c'est que je pense et
c'est ce que monsieur dupont-aignan a
tiré comme leçon de 2017 que par rapport
à maintenant l macron qui incarne une
certaine nouveauté il faut en mettre une
envie une envie de france georges en
tout cas l envie de changement peut
réaliser des partis traditionnels
absolument en face nous on est quand
même des partis à ses anciens et qui
avance sur tout un programme qui
commence un peu à s'user et je crois que
on est tellement parfois sur de nous
qu'on se rend pas compte que notre
programme c'est un peut s'user et la
primaire comme l'avait fait monsieur
montebourg avec hollande avec la
démondialisation il avait apporté des
nouvelles idées à cette famille
politique et monsieur hollande avait pu
s'en saisir et faire une surprise
donc il faut pas les faits tout le monde
parle de personnes mais tout mon crois
que monsieur dupont-aignan veut la place
mais ça n'a aucun sens puisque lorsque
sa fille monsieur dupont-aignan
olympique vers la piste à une guerre
d'égos ensuite que les chefs vont
vouloir en fait ce ne seront pas la
santé bien sûr je comprends je comprends
que ça je comprends mais personne ne
voit souffler la grosse hymne à la smac
cette fois c'est que notre camp est en
dépression collective et aux européennes
nord aux européennes le camp n'a pas
fait un bon score je suis désolé vous
l'avez dit vous-même 47% en 2010 7 37%
en 2019
on perd 10 points c'était déjà pas
brillant avant d'aller de la droite unie
oui bien sûr de ce qu'on pourrait
rassembler n'est ce pas dans un contexte
de notre camp des preuves